pommes de prix pour les acadiens atocas
pour les iroquois grande et reine rouge
d'amérique du nord chez les français on
la connaît surtout sous le nom de
canneberges
chaque automne le centre du québec
déroule son tapis rouge pour nous
présenter sa vedette de la saison la
canneberge scam un fabuleux on est
debout espèce de la clin de fruits en
surface cette image est quand même
ou est-ce qu'elle sent avant tout c'est
canneberge là on exporte dans 52 pays 5
en europe aux etats-unis au japon
partout cette plante vivace pousse dans
un sol plutôt sable c'est au moment de
la récolte que les champs sont inondés
ont montclos on fasse un tracteur ou
décrocher les fruits
c'est comme une gamme de cul et ont
ramené fruit d' incroyable chez havas
ont procédé au problème un succès youn
est sûr mais pas au prix avec les poser
dans un camion ses utilisations à
cuisine sont nombreuses puisque son
acidité est la bienvenue dans une
multitude de préparation et sa couleur
rouge vif d'avant attrayante et très
décoratives dans la région est ce qu'un
endroit où vous aimez manger des
produits de cacao
[Musique]
attendez on va y aller
rochette la canneberge ça représente
quoi que genre de défi sa réponse et
l'acidité c'est très agréable c'est le
parfum du fruit le sexe pour ceux de
masquer la canneberge etc trop de succès
c'est comme perdre un peu lol elle est
vraiment la nature de la canneberge de
petits sauts alors décrivez-nous les
plans qu'on a devant nous donc on
utilise la canneberge de l'entrée au
dessert
l'entrée c'est un gravlax de saumon aux
canneberges et romarin j'aime bien
l'association de hermes avec les fruits
embedone d'un peu de votre corps et de
jus de canneberge peuvent ensuite moi je
mets les canneberges achètent
directement sur le saumon ensuite je
veux connaître la saumure sèche qui est
un mélange de gros sel sucre d'érable je
mets du persil frais haché persie
tallien du romarin un peu on recouvre le
saumon complètement recouvert de sel on
en voit sur réfrigérateur deux jours et
puis après deux jours on grince on
éponge ont remis au réfrigérateur pour
faire sécher le gravlax 24 heures après
soyez prêt à servir en tranches et puis
après c'est le jeu les décors et de
canneberges fraîches tranché j'ai mis
une petite huile de pépins de
canneberges pour aromatiser bon l'huile
de pépins de canneberges pour quelqu'un
qui a déjà vu les pépins ces
microscopiques laurent prend pas faire
une bouteille c'est certain que ça doit
prendre pas mal passé comme un peu les
l'huile de pépins de raisin
oui qui fila oui parce qu'il y en a eu
quelques uns comme un secret à
l'intérieur
combier sait ce qu'est la canneberge est
et comme
[Musique]
ok je voyais des toutous petit noyau
mais ça y est comme capitale alvéoles
des secrets que
la principale donc nous avons des côtes
relevé avec une sauce aux surprises à la
cabanasse oui c'est fait comment cette
social c'est canneberges fraîches que
j'utilisais oignons ont fait suer avec
un petit peu de bach après ça je vois
même du sirop d'érable et puis après ça
fontan un litre mijoter une à sel poivre
on réduit la sauce un peu jusqu'à
consistance voulue et puis on sert sur
les conclaves et on a beau pour
canaliser un peu on sort on abdou sow
sont garnis canneberge ce n'est pas un
boucher avec
mathias est une belle découverte ça ça
se trouve c'est un beau mariage
tarte avec un grand beau jeu mais la
pomme dans le fond de la baisse à tarte
et puis après ça la canneberge on finit
avec un grand bol c'est un mélange de
gris l'aude d'un peu de cassonade on
peut mettre sur des rails aussi avec
quelques noix trop souvent associée à la
dinde de noël la canneberge mérite une
place de choix dans nos assiettes pour
cette polyvalence et aussi pour son côté
acidulé ok c'est une première
[Musique]
c'est bon
je m'attendais à quelque chose qu'elle
aime débit ça marche pas tu déposes
sable non juges d'angers l'adage ouvrir
la bouche
[Musique]